all right moving on to a different food
group today we're learning how to make
thai chicken and peanut ramen chef jeff
jackson with smiss food and drug the
sponsors of this segment shows us how
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smith's and as you know today i've got a
special guest with me is my friend
aubriana and she's got some exciting
news for you here in just a bit but
before that it's a little cold outside
and i love to make a nice comforting
warm bowl of soup and we're going to
make today a thai chicken peanut ramen
which is delicious i started with some
coconut milk chicken broth thai chili
paste
uh there's some soy sauce honey in there
really good base for the soup i'm going
to add some mushrooms right now
sorry for this
okay get messy in the kitchen yeah i'm
not making a mess you're not cooking so
there's some bell pepper and then
there's some garlic so i'm gonna give
this a stir and while i do that just go
ahead and tell them this exciting name
yeah so we're excited to announce we are
opening our second marketplace in
henderson nevada so if you've had a
chance to visit one in our sky canyon
store then you know it is a one stop
shop our marketplace is a
multi-department shore store offering
everything you need from groceries to
clothes to toys whatever you need you
got it at the smiths marketplace and we
are opening january saturday 29th it's
coming up it is very exciting yeah i
love the marketplaces uh you can get
everything there just no need to go
anywhere else right exactly it's so
convenient who would have thought you
could have mixed a grocery store with
all of your other essential needs right
that's awesome
okay so that's coming up but let's get
right back to the soup so i've got the
vegetables in here they're starting to
get tender and once they do that then we
want to add some things to we're going
to add a rotisserie chicken if you don't
mind it's just a rotisserie chicken you
find at the deli at your local smiths i
shred it up it's half of a chicken and
throw that spinach in there
and then we're making ramen and so what
we're going to do is add some of just
the regular ramen um noodles
yeah throw them in there no spice packet
we don't want that
because we've got tons of flavor in here
i'm excited about this ramen that's my
favorite super good and so what we're
gonna do is and that will simmer and it
probably only cooks let's do this
cilantro too okay
save some of it oh that's okay no
worries that's insane i love the
sprinkle green stuff on again and she
put it in there already throw it too
quick but what we're gonna do now is
we're just gonna let this simmer until
the noodles finish and then we'll plate
it up and see what it looks like awesome
okay magic of tv and our ramen is done
it looks fantastic smells great um i'm
excited to eat it how about you i'm so
excited
again about the store opening we are
even more excited to open our new
marketplace in henderson nevada come
visit us saturday january 29th our doors
will open at 8 a.m we'll have a nice
starbucks kiosk there to help you start
your day and everything else you may
need right there at the smith's
marketplace so thank you for having me
today sounds great yeah no problem let's
plate this up looks great we've got some
delicious noodles in there and they're
done
it's a great way to use up those uh
ramen noodle packets that you have just
to make them a little bit better so let
me put some broth in there i know
there's some chicken too the broth is
the best part it's so super good it
smells good so if you don't mind
sprinkling on some peanuts mm-hmm
and then maybe a drizzle of sesame oil
so we don't have any green stuff because
she put it all in there before
that's okay it's gonna be delicious
perfect you can find all these
ingredients to your local smiths thank
you so much for watching thank you for
shopping we'll see you all next time bye
i'll take a bowl of that right look good
thank you to smith's food and drug for
sponsoring the segment they have more
than 20 locations across the valley for
this recipe and more just go to
smithsfoodanddrug.com